traen procedentes de alemania ingresa a
la plataforma y estos voluntarios de la
cruz roja esperan para recibir los
cientos de refugiados ucranianos pasan
diariamente por la estación del este de
parís principalmente mujeres y niños más
ya huyó de los bombardeos en kharkiv
espero que todo esto termine y podamos
volver pronto a ucrania sólo quiero
esperar un poco para recuperar fuerzas y
estar dispuesta para ayudar en la
reconstrucción del país
para los refugiados acogidos aquí hay un
giro sorprendente muchos voluntarios
rusos vienen a echar una mano a la cruz
roja que carece de traductores para
asistir y guiar a los recién llegados
anna es de san petersburgo y lleva mucho
tiempo viviendo en francia conoce bien
ucrania ya que viajó hasta allí a menudo
con sus padres con la guerra como se
puede ver para ser sincera cuando empezó
la guerra lloré durante dos semanas
seguidas lo que me devastó totalmente al
principio fue que estas ciudades que
estaban siendo bombardeadas destruidas y
saqueadas eran de hecho en las ciudades
de mi infancia sentí que tenía que hacer
algo
y los casquillos salvo pocas excepciones
la presencia de los intérpretes rusos es
bien aceptada por los refugiados no no
me molesta no hacemos diferencia entre
los rusos y los otros juzgamos a la
gente por sus cualidades y no por su
nacionalidad aquí nos ayudan no hemos
sufrido discriminación todo está bien la
unión europea creó un estatuto de
protección temporal para los ucranianos
que les permite vivir y trabajar en los
estados miembros de la unión europea por
un año anna quiere ayudar tanto como sea
necesario y mientras pueda
soy una mujer de acción estoy
acostumbrada a la acción y cuando hay un
problema hago todo lo que puedo para
resolverlo aquí no puedo resolverlo pero
puedo ayudar un poco
muchos rusos que viven en francia
comparten la angustia de anna y
denuncian públicamente la guerra una
libertad de expresión impensable en
rusia donde el simple uso de la palabra
guerra puede llevarlos a la cárcel